(calm music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link,
this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're gonna move into a commune.
- We both have our laptops out.
I mean, you know, things
about to get serious
when there's research happening.
- We've got a big decision to make
because we just have
to decide which commune
we're gonna move into.
There's lots of them spread
across this grand globe.
- You wanna pinky swear right now?
- Yep.
- That
- [Both] We are gonna join a commune
by the end of this thing.
- Podcast episode.
- Here's the thing,
we don't believe that
pinky swears are binding.
That's the sort of the catch
22, don't get your hopes up.
But I am seriously considering it.
- So maybe there's a commune
that's an anti pinky swear commune
and we'll fit right in.
People pinky swearing at all times
knowing that it's always meaningless.
- No, a dinky square. (laughs)
- A dinky square?
- A dinky square.
- That's like a really small square?
Look at that dinky square.
- That's when you put
your dinkies together.
- What is a dinky?
- I mean, I think it's another name-
- You're motioning something is if
you're not making this up as your saying-
- A wiener.
- You're calling a wiener a dinky?
- I never had before,
I was just trying to come up with a joke.
You saw a "Bad Trip".
- I saw the first half of
it and then I fell asleep.
- Did you get to the, to the dinky part?
- Oh, yes, the finger trap-
- Don't, I mean.
- It wasn't fingers that were in there.
I mean, what a, what a crazy movie.
- Yeah, it's nuts, man.
- Dang, I've got, it's my rec today.
I reserve the right to recommend
the first half of "Bad Trip".
I don't know, it's kinda,
you know, if you doze off
and then you wake up .
and you're like, maybe I
can just keep watching this.
- Oh yeah, you can doze off and come back.
- That happened but there's
so many points in "Bad Trip"
that like waking up and
realizing what you're watching
is like, it was frightening.
Like I was shocked.
It's like, that's not how a man
wants to wake up on the couch.
In a finger trap with
other things trapped in it.
- Jessie and I watched it together
and the thing that she
was saying, she was like,
I don't know if you can make
this kind of movie anymore.
Like seriously, because-
- Well, it just was made.
- I know, I know, that's the thing,
she was like, I don't know
how I feel laughing at it
because taking advantage of people
and like the idea of consent
is something that if you're
making really crazy prank videos
you're not getting any of that
because you want to get
the authentic reactions.
Now I'm not, I'm not taking a stand
on saying that I think prank
videos should be outlawed.
- And we don't know that they
didn't get post scene consent.
- Yeah, but is that consent?
That's not the conversation
we're having today.
- Let's, what, just get away from this!
So yeah, I don't know if
we're recommending it.
It frightened me when I woke up.
- Yeah, yeah.
We just watched it,
we're not recommending,
we're just talking about it.
- You know, I teased to
this in the last episode,
as the world, I mean,
we're looking through
this Los Angeles lens
of return to normalcy from COVID
and being locked down,
quarantined, safe and what,
you know, and doing all these precautions.
But so maybe we're a little behind,
maybe you're in a spot
where you're listening
and you're like, well,
things feel kinda already
back to normal for me.
- I'm mouth kissing strangers already.
I mean, I don't know.
- But at this point right now
I am very much trying to figure out
how I'm going to re-engage
with my life as it was.
- And a lot of people, I've seen,
it was funny 'cause right when I began
sensing this in myself
and I was talking about it with Jessie,
you know, she's a Twitter queen,
she immediately points
me to like five tweets
that had already emphasized
the same sentiment which is,
as things get ready to turn back to normal
you start feeling a little anxiety
about life returning to normal.
Now, for some people that might be like-
- And sometimes not just a little anxiety.
- I mean, some people it might
be like a social anxiety,
like I don't want to get around people.
That's not it for me, it's just,
and I'm not much of a routine person
but there's something about the fact that
we've been able to conduct our business
kind of uninterrupted, right?
We're one of the lucky privileged
that we get to do our
business in a way that is,
I mean, it's changed a lot
but it's unencumbered in a lot of ways.
- Our business has been
altered drastically,
but we've gotten so used to
it that it is the new normal.
And I mean, that's a whole other podcast
to get into all of that but.
- But being at home, not traveling
a lot like we used to do.
I mean, I haven't been going to the gym
and I kinda turned my
garage into a gym, you know.
And I kind of am into this
sort of predictability
and routine and sort of
like the simple life.
Being home every night.
- I'm surprised to hear
that from you because
that's not something I
would expect or that's not,
maybe it surprises you that you
have those feelings as well.
- I'm ready to travel
but I'm not ready for the day to day life
to turn back into always
all over the place.
- Hectic scramble.
But you know for me and
my personality type, like,
totally gotten used to
my world being smaller
and more predictable and insulated.
And it just feels, I mean, more narrow
but there's a good side to that too
because there's a sense
of increased safety
and you know, for me, control.
- Safety?
Oh, yeah, control, I understand.
- I mean, it started with safety.
and so you kind of have this
ingrained sense of like,
some people may struggle
with this innate feeling of
I've trained myself to believe
that safety is hunkered down
so going out must mean the opposite.
Even though being fully vaccinated
and the realities of full vaccination
and the safety associated with that
is just something that like
the facts don't immediately
translate into feelings
is what we're, that's a big
discussion that's happening
in our home.
You know, I was even
telling Lincoln last night,
I was trying to paint a
picture for, you know,
once we're fully vaccinated
these are some things
that we can start doing.
And he got this look on his face
like he hadn't even thought about it.
You know, it's like, because you go,
you live in this space where it's like,
you just don't even
think about what could be
or what you're missing
out on type of thing.
And then so it's like
you compartmentalize.
And so me giving him, just
starting to paint a picture
for how things could open up, it was like,
he got this, he just
kind of stare for a while
and then he got this big grin on his face
- It must be nice, you
mean, you're telling me
that your kid hasn't constantly
berated you for a full year
about how all this stuff he can't do?
Constantly arguing with you about that?
Because that's the way
it's been at my house.
- Yeah, so it's kinda like when you let a,
you know, you got this dog in a kennel,
maybe they've been in
there for a long time.
Maybe it's their safe cave space,
and then you open the
door and you're like,
he's just layin' there.
- I think what you're saying-
- He's not bursting out.
- Is that your family
is much more susceptible
to being in a cult than mine.
- Which brings me to this sense
of a commune because like,
as we've been talking about
communes I've had to really work
to not use the word
cult every single time.
- Well there's a reason
that they're associated.
- But there's some overlap
that we can talk about.
But yeah, this like,
instead of returning back
to the big wide world,
what if I just skipped
over to commune life
where it's, you know, a
defined group of people
with shared values that
are keeping things simple.
- And you have to imagine
that most people who are in communes
who were in communes before COVID
and in communes through
COVID and after COVID,
their lives have probably
changed the less.
- COVID what?
- They're like, I mean,
yeah, we're in a commune.
Big whoop.
- I mean, sustainability,
peaceful cooperation,
no bills, no boss.
- Eh, no boss.
- No responsibilities.
- Think again, my friend.
- Just food that everyone gets to eat.
No competition.
- It does seem wonderful.
- Connecting with nature
and with strange people
who are misfits in normal
society, but perfect fits
in some of these communes
that we'll talk about.
I'm like, let's go!
And I'm not saying it like
the kids use the phrase
as like just a form of-
- They say let's go?
- Like a positive expletive.
Yeah.
- No, like you mean like
that's a new slang or a?
- What?
I mean, it's a few years old
but everybody's like, let's
go, if they like something.
- But this is like newer
than just like 50 years ago,
let's go, like you
would say to like a team
that you're cheering
for, this is like slang?
- I've heard your own children say that.
- I don't listen to
what my kids talk about.
- You haven't heard, like, I
mean, if you listen to DaBaby
every so often he's gonna
interject, let's go!
And he's not asking people
to come with him somewhere.
He's just like, it's a celebratory phrase.
- But I don't think it's changed.
I thought what you were saying
is that let's go has changed
meaning since like the 50s.
And I don't think it has.
- Yes, it has.
It doesn't mean, let's gather together
and head towards the same destination.
- I know, I'm just saying that like,
let's go, like get pumped up, yeah.
- That's not what it means now.
It doesn't mean, let's get pumped up.
- Okay, what does it mean now?
- It means, I'm excited.
(Rhett laughs)
- It feels like some semantics here.
Let's get excited, oh no, what did I say,
let's get pumped up and let's get excited
sort of feel like the same thing.
- Let's go is trying to pump someone up,
like to conjure up the
energy to do something.
But let's go, it's just like, I love this.
I'm celebrating this.
I don't need to conjure anything up.
I have an overflow of emotion
that now translates into a
hip hop track interjection.
- So you're not saying you
want to go to a commune,
you're saying you're
excited about the idea.
- No.
- So you are using it in the 50s way.
- I'm using it in the traditional
old out of touch sense
that you should understand.
- I'm not confused.
- Let's you and I head
towards the world of communes
and decide which one we
want to physically go to
and live, okay, are we clear?
- Yeah, I'm clear now.
- But yeah, they want them to be called
intentional communities because
people intend to go there
and they're not like held
there against their free will,
at least that's what they say.
- Well, communes have a bad
rap, which we'll get into.
- Well, a throwback to a
conversation we had with the,
when we were talking about
Pythagoras, he is credited-
- We're always talking about Pythagoras.
- As creating the first
intentional community
in recorded history at
Homakoeion, it's a Greek word,
in 525 BCE.
They tried to create an ideal society,
gave up private property and meat.
and apparently beans
as well as we discuss.
- I would just interject quickly here.
- People were getting killed.
- I take issue with this.
This is kinda like when
a white guy in a boat
like discovers something that
brown people who've been living
there for thousands of years
have already known about for along time.
- I guess that's fair, yeah.
- Because intentional community
is basically the history
of the human race.
Like the idea of private property
is something that the western world
brought over here to the Native Americans.
So like the idea of
intentional community I think
is actually the baseline
understanding of human community,
but it wasn't until
agriculture and property
and all that stuff that we didn't have
to kind of undo that to then
create what we're calling
an intentional community,
I guess in 525 BC.
- Yeah.
Okay, point taken, within the context of-
- Western civilization.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Then you've got to have,
if you have the shared
belief or approach to life
that means you're gonna give
up your personal belongings
which you have.
If you're giving it up
in order to be a member of a community
where you're sharing everything-
- Basically post property ownership.
Post the idea of property ownership, yes.
- I mean, the early Christians,
they lived communally.
A few centuries later
Christian monasteries
became a major form of international,
I said international,
intentional community.
So we could become monks.
- You know, this is interesting
'cause I'm reading this book
kind of about early Christian history
and it's actually kind
of fascinating just how,
you know, whatever word you wanna use,
communist, socialist, progressive,
whatever you wanted to use,
that early Christians were at the time.
And I'm not talking about
in the like sense of like
the way they saw
government or necessarily,
but just the way that their community
was very much communist in the
strictest sense of the word.
And it was like, it was the lower class,
it was men and women,
and it was so interesting
that Christianity got
hijacked by the powers that be
and kind of became what
it has been for, you know,
well over 1,000 years.
But in the early stages it was very,
it was a kind of a different thing.
It was a lot more about class
and it was a lot more about
kind of rebelling against
the powers that be
and then the powers that be were like,
oh, we can use this to our advantage
and kind of created the hierarchy
that we kind of see within
the, you know, the church.
- Am I right in remembering
that in Paul's letter
to one of the churches
he kind of talks about the
mechanism of sharing everything.
And he kind of puts some
specifics in that about like,
kind of like the heart
and the motivation behind
giving up your possessions
for the common good.
- I'm sure he talks about that.
I mean, I think it's
mostly in Acts, you know,
Luke wrote Luke and Acts and so.
- Ah, that may be what I'm thinking about.
- Acts, basically the
history of the early church
kind of talks about what they did
and kind of sold their possessions
and came together and live communally.
and were kind of specifically,
specifically reacting
to what was happening
on a societal level,
and that was one of the things
that made it attractive.
And also controversial at the time
because it was kind of saying
that the authority doesn't lie
with these dudes who say
that they're in charge,
authority lies with God.
But it quickly got taken
and, you know, distorted,
in my opinion.
- We could also go to
Israel and join a kibbutz
kibbutz, kibbutz, I think
is how you would say it.
I mean, those are around now.
They've been around and there's like,
there's the religious and
the non-religious kind.
And there's a lot more of
the non-religious kibbutz.
Sorry, I apologize if
I'm saying that wrong.
- Well, and I would think
that this is something
that especially with
what we're seeing with
what we've experienced in
2020 and 2021 thus far,
you know, this deep wealth inequality
and people just, so
many people struggling.
I think the idea of kind
of stepping out of this
pursuit of the American dream.
And I know, you know,
we're not talking about just Americans,
but we're in America.
It's gotta be an attractive thing, like,
you mean I can quit trying
to keep up with the Joneses
and worry about-
- Don't cliche the Joneses.
- Going to the right college
and getting the right job
to pay off the deep debt
that I acquired in order to go to college.
The idea of saying, hey,
can't we all just get along?
I believe that this has never
been a more attractive idea.
I mean, in recent history,
this has got to be
a super attractive idea right now.
So I do think that we
probably should start with
some cautionary tales
before you get too excited.
- Okay, yeah.
- About being a part of a commune,
or an intentional community.
- All right, let's get into the bad news.
Or just, you know, we
need to tread lightly.
- The one that you've all heard
about, Jonestown Massacre,
where the saying, don't drink
the Kool-Aid comes from.
Late 70s.
- I did not know the details of this.
- Yeah, so lots of
really good documentaries
that you can watch about this.
But late 70s, Jim Jones was a preacher.
He began his commune for
social justice and equality,
he was calling it the People's
Temple, that sounds good.
For the people, you know.
- It's got like a temple
in it, that seems fancy.
- But then he made the move,
he moved it from San
Franciscu, San Franciscu.
- San Franciscu.
- San Francisco to Guyana.
First of all, you just gotta,
okay, maybe a red flag here.
He's moving further away
from prying eyes, right,
I mean, that's one way to see it.
And I think that's what was happening.
So people started to,
because there was a lot of American people
who were involved with
this and they were worried
that they were being
held against their will
and it kind of became this story,
so much so that a congressman, Leo Ryan,
decides to visit to make sure
that the residents are okay.
- And this is the late 70s.
- Late 70s.
And he shows up along with four others
and they are shot to death
when they get out of the
plane at the airstrip.
So another red flag.
- Yeah, that's not a good start
to the diplomatic oversight mission, dang!
- And then shortly thereafter,
I don't really remember the timeline,
but Jones, he forced
or strongly encouraged
his followers to drink a
cyanide laced flavor aid,
starting with the children.
- Poor Kool-Aid, it wasn't even Kool-Aid.
It was flavor aid, you know,
but now you got this saying,
don't drink the Kool-Aid.
Matter of fact, I heard it
on an episode of "Survivor".
You hear it everywhere,
but of course, I hear
everything on "Survivor"
'cause that's all I listen to these days.
- It's your sole source of media.
- That's gonna have to be
in any commune I attend.
- Don't drink the flavor aid
just doesn't sound quite,
'cause like, what's flavor aid?
So some people tried to
flee and they shot them.
- Kool-Aid survived it,
but those people didn't.
- Some people tried to
flee and they shot them.
- 'Cause they didn't drink the Kool-Aid.
- And over 900 people were killed.
Almost 1,000 people.
- That is gross.
So anyway, I mean, it's-
- 900 people!
- It may have sounded
awesome at the beginning.
- That's a lot of flavor aid.
- So that's one cautionary tale.
- Gosh.
Now you and I have talked
about the Source family before,
we may have talked about it on this show,
there was a Netflix documentary.
In the wake of, what was
that Netflix documentary
that the Duplass brothers
were executive producers on?
Country, back country?
- Nope.
- No country for commune people.
- "Wild, wild country".
- Great!
- Feeling when you remember
some great that you'd forgotten.
So on the heels of that
I think we were looking
for other stuff to watch
and I watched the documentary,
you watched it too,
on the Source family.
- This is a great documentary as well.
- World War II vet who
became known as Father Yod.
- Great name.
- Yeah, I don't think that was
his original name Father Yod.
That's one thing I love about communes
is that you can change your name.
You can change everybody's
name as it turns out.
He created the first
vegetarian restaurant in L.A.
Had many young wives and
had many younger children
with those young wives,
that's how children work.
They recorded music and sold the albums.
Very hippy dippy like.
- Seemed like a great time.
- 70s situation.
You know, you gotta watch
who you're following
because this is when this stuff, you know,
this is when you get into cult territory
in both of these situations.
But the thing that I didn't realize
until I went back and read about this
was how Father Yod died.
They had moved, they'd
sold their restaurant
and moved to Hawaii in 1974.
And then on August 25th,
1975, according to Wikipedia,
despite having no previous
hang-gliding experience
Father Yod decided that he
would indeed go hang-gliding,
presumably solo.
Yod used a hang glider to
leap off a 1,300 foot,,
that's 400 meters Rhett, cliff
on the eastern shore of Oahu.
Spoiler alert, he died,
I already said that.
He crash landed on the beach, get this,
suffering no external injuries.
He just looked like Rick
Rubin lying on a beach.
You know, it's just like
white dude with a really long white beard.
You know, like Rick looks like these days,
just laying on a beach
suffering no external injuries.
But he was unable to move
and he died nine hours later.
That's a horrible death.
If that's what getting into
a commune means I'm out.
I mean, there's a guy
at the end of my street
who has a hang glider.
And I look at that thing and it freaking,
it makes my balls hurt.
- I don't understand that.
- You never stood on the edge of a cliff
and your balls hurt?
- You say all's hurt you
say this every single time.
- It's a defense mechanism
for not falling off a cliff,
or Yodding your way down on a hang glider.
- Well, I didn't-
- My Yods tell me,
don't hang glide.
- Oh, I didn't tell you this,
so, you know, a couple of weeks ago
we talked about the eject button
that you press in order to-
- Lots of convo about that.
- Leak the lizard.
And in our conversation
that you weren't able to join last night
with our college friends,
it was confirmed that neither of them
knew about the buttons.
- What?
- Yeah, they didn't have, they
haven't pressed the button.
So apparently something I
thought was very common.
- We educated a lot of
people is what I learned.
- Yeah.
So anyway-
- Especially me taking
it to the next level.
- Okay, so yeah, I don't know,
I know how it ended for Father Yod,
and first of all, I do
remain open to the fact
that I might be Father Yod reincarnated
just because of the time of his death
and the time of my birth
and this is the way we look.
- Your affinity for hang-gliding.
- I like the idea of
hang-gliding, never done it,
but it doesn't make my balls
hurt when I think about it.
- But let's get into some
current ones and make a decision.
But first let's promote some merch.
- Speaking of cults and communes, I mean,
this is one of the more
culty Illuminati ish.
- Let's make sure they can see it.
- I mean, basically, you know,
this is supposed to be a magic eight ball
but it's that triangle,
which is the, you know,
which is definitely an
Illuminati ish mythical outlook.
What does it say, Good Mythical Morning?
- Outlook Mythical, yes.
- Outlook Mythical.
- It just says Mythical,
Mythical, Outlook Mythical.
- Oh, okay, Mythical,
- And if you shake it changes.
- Yeah, it changes, in your brain.
- We should have made the
shirt where when you shake
the friction with your
booby area or sternum
makes that triangle make
something else appear
- Do you think we could have
put a little pocket in there
that held liquid and a little dice?
- Why don't we just make it a hole?
You can just see your
chest hair through it.
Well, why don't we sell a t-shirt
with two holes over the nipples?
- Not everybody's nipples
are in the same place,
I've thought about this many times.
- Cut 'em yourself, but
we sell the scissors.
- Okay, all right.
- Mythical.com
- You might be onto something.
- Rep your boys.
- Okay, tell us about a current cult
that we might want to join.
- I wanted to start close,
okay, so in America.
- Sorry, commune, I keep
saying cult, I'm sorry.
- I know, it's hard, and there's for that.
- Commune, intentional community.
- So let's go to central Tennessee
near the town of Summertown, Tennessee.
This place is called the Farm.
There's 200 residents.
- I like everything about this so far.
- It started in the
70s by this hippie guy,
last name Gaskin.
He still lives there but I mean,
this commune, which is like, you know,
it's out in rural Tennessee,
you got a whole bunch of buses
that people are living in.
- Buses?
- It got up to like 1200 people in the 80s
and then they kind of,
they had to change things
in order to, they had a lot of debt
and then they had to
figure out how to, okay,
you gotta start supporting yourself.
And of course, a lot of
people left when they're like,
hey, it's a commune but
you support yourself.
- Yeah, what's the point?
- That doesn't work.
But they were kind of revamped everything
and they developed their own
little cottage industries
and now they're at 200 people
and you can go visit
for like a long weekend
and decide if you want to stay there.
It seems like a lot of
journalists go there
in order to write a little piece
to titillate the minds of people like us.
But I mean, I'll just point out
some of the pros with this place.
It's in America, so it's accessible to us.
- I've been to Tennessee.
- If you need to get
to Nashville, you know,
in an hour and a half
or so you can do that.
- Is it close to Gatlinburg?
'Cause that's what I'm concerned about.
- They have an extremely
successful midwifery, you know.
- People who help you have birth?
- Yes, the wife of the founder,
I think her name's like
Ida May or something,
she's more famous than him
because of the book she
wrote about midwifery.
In fact, the Farm was the
setting for the rebirth
of midwifery for the United States
and the creation of the
modern home birth method.
- Wow!
- And movement.
- I love watching those on YouTube.
- So you can live in a bus and
then have a baby in the bus.
- So is this just people who
are members of the commune
who are having babies?
Or is it like, if you want
to have a baby, you can go?
- I don't know, but I think
because she's so famous
maybe people will go to her for,
I mean, if you really want
to like have a famous midwife
she's the one, she's the one.
- She's still around?
- Yeah.
You gotta be a vegan.
But that's kind of an
assumption for all of these.
- That seems right.
- And there's a lot of, you know,
with the whole change over and everything,
there are still some
residents that were there
from the beginning in the 70s
and went through the whole change over
and they saw it in all its glory.
And like I said,
even the founder and
his wife are still there
but there's a lot of infighting
between those boomers
and newer residents who are coming in,
trying to do it differently.
Which that kind of reminds me,
you have this idea of
you've got this group
of like-minded people that
you're living off the land
and supporting each other
and every, you know,
everybody helps raise the
kids and you share everything.
But, and this is not really
that much of a legitimate comparison
but it's kind of all that I have to go on.
Like in all the like Bible study groups
that I was involved in, you
were involved in growing up,
especially like the young married groups,
like once we graduated from college.
For me, it was like, it
was no way like a commune
except that like you get
together with these people
and you start making these connections
with a small group of people
and it gets really exciting.
And over the course of
my life in that world
there were a few phases or iterations
of a small group getting together,
like a Bible study or like a family group
or whatever you might call it,
and you'd be like, this
is a magical connection.
We all really like each other,
it's like, now we have this
like dynamic friend group
and it never, it never lasts
more than like two years.
Because you know what,
it comprises of people.
People like getting in
each other's business
is a tough thing to maintain.
And even when it just comes to,
hey, let's get together once a week
and encourage each other
and help each other
and in this case study
the Bible, it was like,
we were all very well-intentioned
and it wasn't that,
it wasn't dogmatic in really any way.
But still personalities and like
the slight different pulls of agenda.
I want it to be like this,
well, I wanna do this and
this is the vision I have
and my needs aren't being met,
my expectations aren't being met.
Any group of people,
it's not just a church
thing or a commune thing,
it's so hard to keep it going.
- There's an additional factor
that may actually be the
sort of foundational problem,
even beyond the personalities.
- Hang gliders?
- Not hang gliders.
The fact that you don't
have to be in that group.
In the modern world every
community that you're a part of,
that's why they call it
intentional community,
it's not, we have no choice
but to be this community.
- That's called a prison.
- Right.
- Or a cult.
- Well, no, but if you go
back, okay first of all like,
if you go way back in the distant past
where there was no choice
but to be a part of your community,
and even in some places still in the world
where it's just like, I can't,
I don't make the choice
about where I go to church.
There's one church in town.
I don't make the choice about
what religion I'm gonna be,
there's one option in
this particular place.
And when your community
is constituted in that way
there's just so few choices
that those personalities
are something you deal with,
but in the modern world and modern America
in the south world, and this
is true in all of America but,
like if you think about
this Bible study group,
if I don't like the voice
of the person leading the Bible study
I can go to another Bible
study in the same church
or I can go to another church.
- Probably in the same house.
If you want an all women's one,
that one's happening downstairs.
- We're overwhelmed with options and so,
I mean, you literally can
go to a first Baptist church
or a second Baptist church
or even in some towns
I've seen a fricking third
Baptist church in the same town
and that's just the Baptists.
And that's just the Christians.
- Let's not just pick on churches.
- I'm saying, this is everybody.
- Any group of people.
Like, if you want to talk about, you know,
I mean, our friend group
post church, you know?
It was like, there was
a dynamic experience
for like a little over a year
and then things just, you know,
people went their separate ways.
- Well, a lot of people have said,
even after us telling our
stories and, you know,
because we exhibit an openness
towards spirituality in general
and we're not trying to be
like naturalists, atheists,
and just basically rule
out all mystical things,
people are like, you know, it sounds like
you guys would really enjoy a
Unitarian Universalist church.
Now, I'm not saying I wouldn't
and I'm not saying that
I would never try it,
but the idea that somehow
because that particular group of people
is committed to a more open
or progressive mindset,
that then there would no
longer be the problems
of people working together
and ego, that's just not true.
No matter how wonderful
the foundational principles
of your community,
like you said, it's still gonna be people,
and it's still gonna be people
in the context of this
society where I can be like,
I don't have to be at this place,
I can just go to the other place.
And as long as those options exist
long-term peaceful community of any kind
is gonna be very difficult.
- Even if you don't, to
get back to communes,
you don't have like a
strong centralized leader,
like a dictator that kind
of makes it more cultish,
I was reading about another
one in Virginia that like
they all shared the duties
of raising the children
in this particular commune.
And there was a couple that
wanted to have another child
but there was a protocol
that you had to go and get permission.
- Because we all got to
take care of this kid
- To have a child, so it's like,
it's even coming from like a
logistic place that makes sense
but you find yourself
having to get permission to have a child?
- Well, which is something
that completely rubs up against
the rugged individualism
of our modern society,
and especially America.
The idea that I would have to,
that I wouldn't own this piece of property
and the fact that I'd have to
ask permission to have a kid,
it seems almost offensive to most of us.
But I do think the idea that,
hey, I'm a member of this collective
and every decision that
I make is gonna impact
every other member of the collective,
it kind of makes sense,
it sort of follows.
But it violates our
sense of individualism.
- I mean, we went to different
churches as newlyweds
and as we graduated from college.
We didn't actually, you know,
we never went to the same,
we grew up in the same church
but we didn't go to the
same church after college.
- Right.
- Until the point where we
no longer went to churches.
- We didn't think people could handle us
going to the same church.
- I mean, it was good to have
some autonomy but I mean,
so in that phase of life
did you have a similar
experience to me that like,
you had this supercharged small group
that you thought was gonna
be like connected forever?
Did you experience the magic
before the disappointment?
- I wouldn't say it was as a marked
of magic and a disappointment
as it seems like you're talking about,
but I completely understand.
I mean, we had a pretty consistent group.
It was sort of a core group of people,
probably four, five, six years or so.
But again, it was the kind of thing
that we came together as a Bible study
and it was a great time,
but there wasn't a
whole lot of interaction
outside of that group and then Sunday.
Because everybody had other friends
and everybody had their
lives and their jobs.
Again, you did, there was nothing
that was forcing your
involvement with the other family
and so it wasn't as, it
just wasn't as stark.
But yeah, I completely
get what you're saying.
- I'm passing on the Farm because
I'm not gonna have any more kids
and I love the idea of living
in a van, but not a bus.
- The reason I'm passing
on the Farm is because
it just doesn't seem cool enough to me.
But I'm about to give you something
that I think is getting into,
because if I'm gonna do a
commune, I want it to be weird.
- Let's go!
- How about Auroville
in Indiana, or India.
- I thought I said Indiana,
India, man, big difference.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's not Indiana,
I was telling you a curve
ball, this is in India.
- You gotta travel to this
one, it better be good.
- Now you can go to the
Auroville.org website
which has got a lot of content.
Okay, this is a multicultural
city started in the late 60s.
They believe in human unity
and transformation of consciousness.
Over 3,000 residents from 58 nations.
Residents are expected
to build their own house
and make donations to the community,
but beyond this, all necessities,
including public school,
utilities, healthcare, are
covered by the community,
which is technically partially funded
by the Indian government, but
let's not complicate things.
Now, let me just say,
I have created what I'm calling
the cool shit factor, okay?
- Okay, yeah.
- To judge these communes by.
- All right, all right.
- And Auroville-
- That's really what it's all about.
How cool is your shit?
- Auroville has a lot of cool shit
and let me just tell you a few things.
- The first thing-
- I see these pictures, man.
- Now, they started the
community in this area in,
not Indiana, India, and they decided
that the center of the
entire thing would be this,
I think it's banyan tree, I
think it's how you say that.
But those are those sort of iconic,
you've seen these trees on like postcards
if you haven't seen them in person.
- The Buddha was enlightened under one.
- And so there's this Banyan
tree that is in the middle
of this kind of stark landscape
and they decided that this was
the center of the community.
I just like that kind of thing.
You know, me and you with our
like declaring a tree special.
- Yep.
- We do this.
But they didn't just say,
hey, here's a tree, no.
Then they constructed this
thing called the Matrimandir,
and this is-
- Matrimandir.
- It looks like a golden
Epcot Center, right?
- The shiny Epcot sphere.
- The sphere at Epcot.
And this thing has took forever to build,
But, first of all, you
can visit this thing,
like anybody can visit this thing.
But inside this golden ball structure
there is the largest optically perfect
glass globe in the world.
And on the website, they go through
how they had this thing manufactured.
- So like a big paperweight.
- Well, but it's optically perfect.
- Hold on, optically,
meaning it looks perfect
but it's probably not?
It's not microscopically perfect.
- Well, I think it's as perfect,
there's no other glass globe of this size
that is this perfect.
- And what did they do with it?
- I mean, I'm sure they get
energy from it or something.
I don't know, it's cool.
- They meditate on it.
Do you sit on it and try to hatch it?
- I don't think you sit on it.
I think that would probably
be like a violation.
- Yeah, that's probably rule number two.
- I don't even know if you
can touch it or lick it.
- That's rule number one.
- But you can look at it.
I'm sure we're gonna get
facts wrong about this,
sorry those of you who are like from,
welcome, first of all,
those of you from Auroville
who are watching, welcome to the show.
- Thanks, we think you got
some cool shit going on.
- It's a podcast called "Ear
Biscuits", we do it every week.
- We're coming for ya.
- If you wanna broadcast this.
You could broadcast this inside the,
I know I'm saying it wrong, Matrimandir.
- Put this on repeat,
like this part of the
podcast, just loop it.
- You know what, feel free.
We are officially giving
you permission to take this,
our description of your place
and put it in a little video
vignette on your website.
Okay, in like a video
brochure, if you will.
Anyway, you got a lot of cool shit.
And there's also-
- I like that big focal point,
the Epcot focal point.
- I don't wanna just
show up and see buses.
- Yes, exactly.
- I want to see something that like,
oh, that alien may have been involved.
They don't just have that,
they have a giant amphitheater
and in the middle of the amphitheater
is just this marble urn.
Just a marble urn.
- I see a picture where they're
like, there's a huge fire.
- Yeah, I mean the website's got
some very intoxicating images.
So anyway, I know there's more cool shit,
that's just what we're
gonna talk about now.
The pros of this one,
you got your healthcare,
your school taken care of, you
can stay for a trial period.
- Okay, how long is that?
- I don't know.
- As long as it needs to be.
- Large group, diverse group,
very high cool shit factor.
It was started by a woman
they called the Mother.
And I want to take a
second to camp out here,
because you know, I'm
generalizing, but you know-
- Does everyone camp out there?
- When a dude starts a
cult 99.7% of the time
it's because he wants to
get with a bunch of women.
- He wants to get his Yod
on, or get his Yods off.
- But a woman, in my experience,
women are not just interested
in ripping families apart
and having sex with everybody
as much as men tend to be.
- Wow, Rhett.
- So I think that there could be,
this could be a purer motivation here.
They call her the Mother
and I think the fact that
she started, now she's dead,
But I think she, according to them,
she passed on into a different form
and still is involved in some way.
Maybe she's in the ball?
Maybe she's in the urn
which would make more sense.
- No comment.
- Again, if you want to take this part
out of the little video
brochure on the website
if I'm getting all the details
about the Mother wrong,
I'm sorry, you can do that.
I'm just saying, I love the fact
that a female started your commune.
Cons, you gotta relocate to India.
You gotta build your own house.
I don't even like to change
the light bulbs anymore.
I mean, I just am gonna be honest,
I did a bunch of like manual
stuff like in my 20s like,
you know, I was like a a Mr. Fix-it man
like working on rental
properties and stuff and I just,
I don't like it.
- You bring up a good point,
I think communes are really for that
like young and vivacious type
that wants to go grab life by the Yods.
- There's a lot of things
I want to do though.
- And then if you're old
it's 'cause you've like,
you've been there for awhile, you know?
- I like the idea of maybe
gardening a little bit,
maybe a little bit of woodwork,
just for like an artistic standpoint,
but not building a house.
- That's a lot.
That's a lot.
- And also, and I don't know
if this is necessarily a con
but you know, the idea is to lose
your sense of personal
possessions and your ego,
which I actually think
that that's a positive.
I wouldn't put that in a con list.
- Sounded like you did.
- Well, I think you put
this in a con actually.
- Yeah, I did.
I love my ego.
- Maybe that says something about you.
I would love to lose, if
I lost my ego completely.
- Yeah, that'd be great.
- Then I would lose any desire
for personal possessions.
So I wouldn't care, so
that's a positive to me.
If I go and I, I guess if I
sit on or touch the glass orb,
maybe my ego gets taken
and stored inside the
optically perfect orb
and then maybe if I want
it and I want to leave
and I'm like, I gotta go
to America, I need my ego,
I'll touch it and get it back.
Is that how it works?
You can take this out of the,
take this off the website
if that's not true.
- I think that one just
rolls into a commune
and then explains how
all of their very meaningful things work.
Hey, I got news for you guys,
I'm gonna be sitting on this orb and I'll,
you know, I'll post the
times when I'm not on it
if you want to bring in
tourists to look at it.
Otherwise you're just
gonna be looking at me
kinda nesting on this thing.
- No, no, I'm not gonna
spend a lot of time,
I'm gonna deposit my ego into it
and then I'm gonna walk out.
And then if I need my ego
for some sort of like competition
or like a sporting event.
I gotta go play golf I need my ego.
- So you're losing your
ego into this sphere,
but you're basically doing that to assert
that you think everyone would
want to look at your ego.
Which kind of doesn't
sound like losing your ego.
- That is how you're interpreting it.
I'm not, you can't see
anything in the orb.
It's not, my ego is not the
only ego that's in the orb.
I'm assuming everyone's ego is in the org.
Orb, but it is an org,
'cause it's Auroville.org is the website.
- But what I'm telling
you, Rhett, is that you're-
- You're misinterpreting
everything that I'm saying.
- No one's ego is in
the orb so if you put-
- You wouldn't make a good cult member.
- If you put your ego in the orb
it's gonna be the only
one in there, period.
You just can't tell people that,
oh, you know everyone,
everyone's ego's in there.
- No, I'm making some assumptions
here and I might be wrong.
I'm just saying, if there
are egos deposited in the orb
or the urn, or the tree,
then I'm part of that,
I'll do that.
- Let's go to Scotland.
I thought you'd be into this.
- Yeah, I was Scotlish
at one time. (laughs)
- The Findorn Ecovillage.
Now don't get your hopes up,
there is no hidden horn.
- 'Cause they found it.
- That's not what this is about.
You know, it reminds me of like,
Christie went to Meredith College,
all women's school where they,
they did all these summer
camp exercises, like by class,
by like freshmen class, junior, senior,
and I think when you were a junior,
you were supposed to find the crook.
That was hidden by the seniors.
And it was, the crook, I
don't even know what it was.
I think it's just, I've never seen it
and I never asked Christie what it was.
I just have this, like a crook at like,
a picture of the bent top of a cane
or like a shepherd staff.
I don't know why,
but that's what I always
thought a crook was
and I'm just now realizing
I've never seen it
or really asked Christie what it was.
- We could probably look
it up on the internet.
- But it was kind of this
game to find the crook,
kind of like finding a hidden
immunity idol in "Survivor".
- Right, uh-huh.
- What?
I actually don't want to be the guy
that keeps talking about "Survivor".
- Well, you're too late.
We found that horn. (laughs)
- But finding the crook is
not like Findhorn Ecovillage.
This thing started in the 60s
but it didn't take his
current form until 1982
When residents made an effort to show
that an environmentally
unobtrusive community
could flourish both
socially and economically
and obviously-
- Spiritually
- No, physically, like naturally.
- Okay.
- It's been noted as the
smallest environmental footprint
of any town in the modern world.
- Whoa, okay, all right.
- Yeah.
They're building codes
encouraged using found materials.
They use wind turbines or turbines,
whatever your jollies are.
And they got a water treatment apparatus
called the Living Machine.
- Okay, I like that, that's weird.
- Which makes use of algae,
snails, and plant life
to purify the community's drinking water.
Oh, that's awesome.
So this place is, you know,
if you look on the website,
it's got this Scottish
countryside farm vibe
but there's actually a lot of buildings
and a good amount of streets.
- How many people, do you know?
- I don't know.
Everybody bikes everywhere.
No one counts how many people there are,
so don't worry about it.
- Got it, got it.
- But yeah, I definitely want a drink
of this living machine.
- I'm into this.
- You have to build a house here too.
- Oh really?
- I mean, there's more restrictions,
you've gotta build it
out of found material.
- Can't you just take, like
people will leave or die.
Can I just take that guy's house?
- Maybe.
- Like, can I get on the
waiting list and be like-
- My ego is gonna live here with you
until you decide to move
out and then I'll move in.
- I want a waiting list
and I just wanna be like,
Hey, I don't really
want to build my house,
but when Walter dies,
he's tall and he's probably
got furniture that fits me.
And he's tall so he won't live long,
put me on the waiting lists for Walter's.
- Some houses are made
from old wine barrels.
That's kind of cool, that's
a cool shit situation.
- You could maybe make
an Instagram with that,
is that allowed?
- I don't know.
- Do any of these places
have an Instagram?
- No, they just have a website.
They're all kind of behind, you know,
they don't really seem to
care about social media.
- Well, Instagram is all about ego anyway
so that's not a good, that's
not a good thing to introduce.
- I don't think you can have
your phone out in public
and then it's hard to get
reception in some of these places.
- That's good, I like that.
- This one's basically
a demonstration farm.
People come and they
visit and they're like,
wow, look at how
eco-friendly this place is
and self-sustaining, it reminds
me of the demonstration farm
on the edge of Buoys
Creek that I never knew,
what was going on there?
- The one near my house?
- Yeah, when I would ride my
bike from my house to yours
I would have to go by
the demonstration farm
and it was a Campbell
University thing, right?
And they had sheep
everywhere and I do remember
that we took a trip there
in like younger grades.
- Well, the funny thing is,
is we took a field trip there
and because it was next to my house
and I was a little boy
who'd got into everything
I was like, I've been up
in this demonstration farm-
- A lot.
- A lot already.
- Yeah, you took me there.
- No, I would go and
I would jump the fence
and I would run around with
the goats and the sheep
and pet 'em and I would get in,
I would get into everything
at the demonstration farm,
without permission.
And then occasionally-
- Would people show up and
would you demonstrate anything?
- I would be like, I'm gonna demonstrate
how a little boy runs from
the farmer once he shows up
- I remember that we would
both kind of scurry around
and you know, trespass in
the demonstration farm.
- There was a male goat
that would ram you.
- Yeah, he was aggressive.
- He was very aggressive,
and I thought it was the coolest thing.
- But the daughter of the
family that lived on the farm.
- Before it became the farm.
That was Jennifer Pearson.
- I didn't think we were
saying last names anymore.
- Oh, okay, Jennifer.
- Wonder what happened
to Jennifer Pearson?
Man, I had a crush on her.
- You did, you really liked her.
- I had a crush on her,
man, in kindergarten.
- I spent the night at her house one time.
- Every time I say that
I had a crush on her,
this is what you say.
You gloat that you spent
the night with her,
with her brother.
- She had a younger brother,
and you know me, I would invite
myself to anybody within-
- He was so much younger.
- Yeah, yeah, he was three
years younger, I think.
- That's a lot when
you're in grade school.
- I would do three years,
three years younger,
there was a six year range
that I felt it was acceptable
to spend the night at somebody's house.
Because I was very interested
in other people's homes.
- I mean, you were like 11 years old
and like you were spending the
night with an eight year old.
That's just weird.
- I readily admit that it's weird.
But it wasn't about him, it was about-
- Was it about the goat?
- It was about, he lived on a
farm, he had a sister my age.
I mean, he accepted my
invitation for myself.
- It was a white house, one story.
I never went inside of it,
I just thought a lot about
what it might be inside.
- I can tell you, I mean,
there wasn't a lot of cool shit in there.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- I mean, maybe that's
true of the Ecovillage.
I mean, basically the
only thing I'm touting
is Scotland is fun.
You can ride your bike everywhere.
- It's dangerous though.
- But you also have to
ride your bike everywhere.
- My mom broke her ankle there.
- Living machine water taste test.
- I like that, I liked that idea.
- It was criticized a few years back
for advertising alternative
healing practices
not recommended by science.
They have since rebranded.
- But isn't that just part of being
in one of these communities?
I mean, the whole new age deal?
I mean, of course they're
healing in ways that don't,
aren't scientific.
That's what it's about, right?
- They're teaching good
things and they're like,
I don't think they're religious
or even philosophical.
It's more just about like,
eco-friendly, self-sustaining.
- Well, that's attractive,
but it's also hard to get
people to fully commit.
- Right, it's a bit.
- You need them to swear
off their own family
and swear allegiance to
something above themselves.
In order to be an
effective commune, I think.
- So Scotland doesn't do it.
I think, you know, gold Epcot.
- Right now the leading
candidate is Auroville.
But I've got one that's gonna
to maybe shake things up.
The Federation-
- I gave you all the good ones.
- Of Damanhur.
- This is a good one.
- In Italy.
First of all, always
wanted to go to Italy,
I mean, just right off the bat.
The Federation of Damanhur,
often simply called Damanhur,
is a commune ecovillage,
that's also an ecovillage,
and spiritual community
situated in the Piedmont region
of northern Italy, about 50
kilometers, about 31 miles,
north of the city of Turin.
Shroud of Turin, anybody?
- Oh yeah, you can swing by the shroud
and then go down there and visit.
I know they make tours because
I watched one on YouTube.
- Yeah, oh yeah, there's, okay,
this thing was founded in
1975 by a dude, Oberto.
- Oberto!
- So there's a questionable deal there
just because a dude founded it.
But he founded it with 24 followers
and by the year 2000 it had grown to 800,
I don't know exactly what it is now
but they hold kind of a mix of
new age in neo pagan beliefs,
which I think is, that feels right to me.
- We're in a sweet spot now, neo pagan.
- Now hold on to your Yods
because the cool shit factor-
- Thank you for using that.
- The cool shit factor at
this place is off the charts.
- But, under the ground.
- The Temples of Humankind.
- Yes.
- We're talking hand dug 100
feet deep tunnels and chambers
that have all this stuff, including.
- I love hand dug stuff.
- But that's 100 feet too, I mean.
- That's crazy.
- I love underground stuff.
I haven't done a whole lot of it
but the idea of being in
caves and underground,
especially a thing that's been
dug into the ground, big fan.
- I'm a fan of it as long
as you can walk around
in a pretty much upright position.
Once you start to belly crawl underground.
- No, no, we're not
talking to spelunking here.
- I've done that before.
- We're not talking spelunking,
we're talking the Hall of Spheres
containing translucent
orbs containing water
imbued with spiritual energy
intended for use in meditation.
So we're not just talking
about one perfect,
we're talking about multiple spear spheres
with water in them that's been imbued.
The Hall of Earth, which
has a dreamlike murals
of landscapes and extinct animals
calling attention to human responsibility
to the planet preservation.
- Yeah, there's like
paintings of these animals
all over the wall and it's
kind of like walking through
a human sized ant farm.
'Cause like, you go through
this, there's a door and then,
you can tell that things
were built on and added
as they went.
- Yeah, 'cause it's
been around a long time.
- It wasn't some grand
scheme to this thing,
it was more like big room, let's
paint it, put orbs in here.
Let's make a tunnel this way,
and so it's, you know, it's very ant-like.
- And I'm not done, Hall of Mirrors,
an area for meditation surrounded
on all sides by mirrors.
- I would expect no less.
- The piece de resistance,
I don't know exactly where it's at,
but I can confirm that on the website,
I saw a woman with a gong.
And if you've got a commune
in there is not a gong,
you have done it wrong.
Just remember that, okay?
- Commune with no gong,
you've done it wrong
- And I've only scratched
the surface so to speak.
I mean, you do have to go 100 feet deep.
But this is a beautiful
area and their website,
their website is crazy,
what is the website?
I guess I just went to,
I get a lot of this from the Wiki entry,
but they've got a good website too
with a lot of information.
And you can visit-
- Damanhur.org
- Okay.
Should be dot orb.
- Sustainability is the
present and the future.
The thing that I noticed is that they,
they've got like these
different, what are they called?
- Symbols?
- These symbols represent,
There was a lot of
organization in terms of like
where you could fit in in this community
and like your level of commitment.
It's a grand system
- But they're not trying to not be culty,
which is something I appreciate.
Let's just go ahead and admit,
that's what we're doing here, guys.
We are a cult, right?
This is not, hey, an intentional
community eco village.
No, it's a fricking cult,
let's be honest about it.
Let's embrace it, that's
why we're doing this.
So I like that about it.
And also I liked the fact that they have
four levels of participation,
A, B, C, and D.
- Well, they call them classes,
that's what I'm talking about.
Just like this whole system
you can assimilate into.
- So one class is you got
to live there full time
and that's class A, class
B, you got to be there
three times a week,
like three days a week.
And then class C and D-
- And contribute tribute money.
- Class C and D you can live anywhere,
but you know, at least it depends on like
what kind of like course you're in,
there's a lot of meditation,
there's a school of meditation.
There's a thing called the game of life.
- What?
- I don't even understand it but I'm in,
and let me say this.
- It's like an underground board game
that you could die?
- Yeah.
The other thing is from 1983 onwards
members have assumed animal names,
and not just animal names,
you get an animal first
name and a plant last name.
So the founder is called Falcon Dandelion.
And I've already picked my name,
I'll give you some time
to think about yours.
- Well Falcon Dandelion is taken.
- I'm going, and just so y'all know,
look out for Giraffe Kudzu.
- Giraffe Kudzu, you got a
long neck and you grow fast.
- That's right.
Giraffe Kudzu in the house.
Where is he at, is he
in the Hall of Mirrors?
No, he's at the gong.
Giraffe's my favorite animal
and they're very tall,
that's simple.
Kudzu is a southern invasive species.
- With that beard of yours,
it's like you don't even have a neck.
- It's not about the neck,
it's about the overall height.
Don't criticize my fricking
name, come up with your own.
Giraffe Kudzu will be, I'm coming
and I want to be the gong operator.
That's the only stipulation.
Multiple gongs, in fact,
I want a Hall of Gongs.
I'm not necessarily gonna dig it,
but I will supervise the digging
and I will supervise the
purchasing of the gongs
and I will attempt to
construct a long stick
that I will use to strike the gongs.
I think I could probably
do that, just find a stick.
- I will be called Trichinosis Rosebud.
Is Trichinosis an animal?
- No, that is a disease
that you get from raw pork.
- Right, but it is an animal.
- I mean, it's worms, I guess.
I think it's the disease
you get from the worms.
Trichinosis Worm Rosebud.
- Rosebud, okay.
- So it's like, I'm entering
into this place and-
- T-W-R-B, Twerb. (laughs)
Can I just call you Twerb for short?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I like that.
Just call me Twerb but I
want you to know that like-
- Twerb, could you fetch a stick for me?
- I'm not trying to, I'm
not a dog, I'm a man.
I'm a man who's, you know what?
I'm coming to you, warts
and all, Trichinosis.
You know, I'm not trying
to be something nice
or something I'm not.
- But what are you gonna do though?
You know what I'm gonna do,
I've already decided that.
- I'll probably dig holes.
- You'll be a digger?
- I'm gonna be a, I like,
I mean, as a kid, man,
I would love to dig a good hole.
- You're also a good cleaner,
you love cleaning things.
Could you clean the gongs?
- Once you dig a hole it creates
lots of debris to clean up.
- I don't think you have
to clean a gong very often.
- I'm not cleaning your gongs, no.
That's an emphatic, no.
- I think you polish a gong,
you like a polishing things?
- I've never, you know what,
I'm gonna answer to this
truthfully and thoughtfully.
- You've never polished anything?
- I can't recall polishing anything.
- The world of polishing is
waiting for Twerb to show up.
- When I first got that
pickup truck when I was 16,
and you know I would wax it,
is waxing a form of polishing?
- Yes, I think waxing is
a sub genre of polishing.
- And Trichinosis is an animal.
- Yeah, okay, you can
have it your way, man.
- I'm a hole digger, man.
I guess if I'm a hole digger
I should be an animal that digs holes.
- Okay, I'm on board.
- I just can't think of one.
- A lot of pros here.
- A dog?
- A lot of pros here,
the name's one of them,
gongs, super high cool shit factor.
You don't have to live there full time,
I think you can come in at level C or D
and kind of feel things out.
- Calling everybody in animal
is some cool shit, man.
- Oh yeah.
Now, there are some cons.
With all the pros that come
from it being very cult-like,
there also some cons, let's be honest.
Basically, the guru makes
all your decisions for you.
There is some estrangement from family.
There's some typical cult situation things
that are happening here.
If you're not comfortable with that,
if you don't like the idea
of being brainwashed and manipulated,
which I understand some people don't,
then this might not be for you.
- None of that came up
in the tours that I saw,
like fun for Louie, remember him?
- Uh-huh.
- He was there with,
shoot, what is that gal's
name who was in our crate?
She was in our crayon colors music video.
Remember way back in the day,
she was a vlogger at the time.
I can't remember her name but she, Nadine,
I think that's her name.
Like they were there
together like many years ago
and like posted YouTube videos.
- Just visiting?
- Just visiting and
like vlogging about it.
And they went through the chambers,
you can experience the
chambers and probably the gong
just by visiting.
- Do you think that the
fact that I said that-
- But they didn't mention
any of this cult-like shit.
- Well, I'm just, first of
all, just for legal reasons
might I say that
everything I'm saying here
is for entertainment purposes.
- Seems like that should go at the top.
- I'm just saying that there's
been, they've been accused,
let's just say allegedly
there are some cult-like
things happening here
and some control issues
that are happening.
But like I said,
I don't think you can do
this properly without that,
you know?
And I'm not trying to
be, you know, listen,
cults, you know-
- They get a bad rap?
- People have suffered incredible horrors
and traumas from cults, so
I'm not saying I'm pro cult.
I'm just saying if you're
gonna do a community
that's got a bunch of cool shit
there's gonna be some mind
control and some manipulation.
It's just kind of part of the package.
You know what I'm saying?
So just keep all that in mind.
You also, if you're gonna
live there full-time
you're gonna be in a house
with 10 to 20 people.
This is gonna be an adjustment.
It's gonna be an adjustment,
I mean for you, you know.
I think it would be an adjustment for me.
Giraffe Kudzu is gonna have
a tough time with that.
But I don't know, I think I could adjust,
I think I could adapt.
- I'm just going to go
back to Auroville in India.
Or maybe Indiana, maybe there's
like a miniature version.
- That quickly you went back?
I mean, I don't know the Auroville
doesn't have some of the same,
what are you afraid of at?
- You scared me off with the,
I mean, not being able
to make any decisions.
- No, you can make decisions,
but you gotta make
decisions that are approved.
- Right.
- It's probably the
same at Auroville, man.
I'll take one gold orb and
one really smooth or within it
instead of all those chambers,
even though I like to dig holes.
- Okay, well.
- I think that's where I'm landing.
- I think I'm going to
Italy, going underground,
assuming that I can get these
things that I've requested
and assuming that the people
are gonna still be okay
with the fact that I said
the stuff about mind control.
Here's what I'm saying,
I understand that it's part of the deal
and Giraffe Kudzu is showing up,
he's gonna be on the gongs,
he's the willing to let
his mind get controlled.
So I'm just saying,
I'm gonna submit when
I get there to my guru.
- Okay.
- Okay?
- So don't sue me.
- Tricky, if you call me
Tricky I might join you.
- Tricky sounds like a
carnie that got fired.
- Short for Trichinosis, man.
- I understand what it comes from, but.
- Well, I've got the rec this week,
I'm gonna, so switching gears a little bit
for a rec baby, rec
baby, one two three four.
I'm gonna recommend a video.
- A video.
- Yeah, I just want you to watch a video.
And this is more for you,
but if like, you know,
I think most everybody listening
would get a kick out of this.
If you Google, well, if
you search on YouTube
I've only eaten Mac and cheese
for the past 17 years, here's why,
a video will show up called,
"I've Eaten Only Mac & Cheese
for the Past 17 Years and Here's Why"
It's on the Vice YouTube channel.
- I know why you recommend this.
- It's almost got 10 million views.
Yeah, I saw this thanks to a Reddit post
on the Good Mythical Morning thread.
And it's a profile piece
of, you guessed it,
a guy who has only eaten Mac &
Cheese for the past 17 years.
And this video tells you why.
As we discussed on Good Mythical Morning,
we did a whole episode about
people eating only one thing.
And it, you know, it did really well,
this is like from many, many years ago,
I barely remember even doing the episode.
But I did remember a little bit
and I knew from the Reddit
thread that there's a connection.
Well, halfway through this Vice piece
as it's doing this profile thing,
this is an 18 minute video,
it's about five minutes in,
that's when he gets into his story of
after having eaten Mac and
cheese for a lot of his life
he talks about how he's
watching this internet show
called Good Mythical Morning
and they show a clip of us
talking about people eating one thing
and like we talk about how
there's a name for that.
- It's a condition.
- It's a mental condition.
And he did not know that
he had a mental condition
until he watched Good Mythical Morning.
And then he goes on and it's like,
and talks about like his treatment.
It's a pretty cool video to watch
and that's the only time we're
mentioned but it blew my mind
and it actually, you know,
if you would've reminded me
that we made that episode of GMM
and then that someone
who has that condition
would have watched it.
You know, I would have
cringed a little bit
and been like, I hope we didn't
hurt that guy's feelings.
- Oh, I think we helped him.
- But we clearly helped this guy.
Like we were the catalyst
to get him on a path
of coming to grips with what
he's dealing with in treatment.
Like there's literally,
it's a little strange
because he goes to a therapist
session and it's filmed,
you know, they filmed the thing.
So there's a strange vibe in that exchange
but maybe it was just because of the fact
that it was a therapy
session being filmed.
But overall I was just, I
was relieved to find out
that we only helped the guy.
So even though we might've
gotten a kick out of
people eating only one thing,
it's more of a fascination
than like making fun of is what
I think we struck a good balance,
one so that we actually
could help this guy.
- Changing the world one
person at a time, man.
- It was surreal to watch
that a couple of weeks ago.
- And it's been out for awhile.
- This video came out a year ago
and then our video was like before that.
- Right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So check that out.
- Did you say the name of it?
- I've Eaten Only Mac & Cheese
for the Past 17 Years, comma, Here's Why.
- Okay, so basically
it's the title is the-
- Yeah, the thing that
I've said multiple times.
Vice YouTube channel.
- Well, thanks for listening to us.
Those of you who are in any of
these intentional communities
who joined us for this episode,
thank you for joining us.
- Let us know.
- We may be joining you soon.
- About your experience.
If you visited a commune
or one of these places,
#EarBiscuits.
- And if we got something
wrong, as I'm sure we did.
In the least how we pronounce
some of these things.
But some of the assumptions that I made
about your establishments,
let us know, #EarBiscuits.
Join the conversation, set us straight.
- We'll talk at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(calm music)